hey everybody my name is Walter Bernays
ik and I am the host of channel awesomes
new show awesome comics debuting on
channel awesome calm Monday March 28th
we are here at c2e2 yeah that's right
the Chicago comic and entertainment expo
to give you the coverage of Friday's
events we're gonna interview people
we're gonna talk to cosplayers or to
give you the overall feel of this
amazing event let's check it out right
now
all right here with Austin st. John the
original Red Power Ranger from Mighty
Morphin Power and just how's it going
awesome it's good man Chicago has been
treating me right that's good place I
love it what is it like to over 20 years
later now since Power Rangers first
debuted and now you're here meeting all
your fans as adults there were kids when
you're watching a show myself included
it what is it like meeting all your fans
I think what I love now is they've grown
up now they're coming up to my table and
they're sharing their stories so we
didn't just reach a bunch of children
and and their parents back then we
reached deeply because they're coming up
and they're telling me stories that blow
my mind you know I love it every day I
just I love here and what people have to
say it's amazing
another thing I want to ask about is the
new Power Rangers movie that's coming
out for Lionsgate are you excited for
that slash are you involved in any
capacity I have had discussions I
currently have no contract so no
promises I'm really curious to see what
they're gonna do
I really AM so I don't know what to make
of it just yet I can tell you I got some
other projects coming up I'm getting
ready to be part of a whole nother
superhero franchise it's called black
salt go to face book black salt go to
the website black salt calm check it out
lots of good stuff coming man great is
there anywhere online that people can
check you out right now yeah go to face
book at Austin Saint John you'll see the
blue checkmark there so the page has
been verified I do a lot of my stuff
there Twitter asj Austin Instagram
Austin hash underscore St underscore
John and then I'm building a website
that I'll advertise across all that
social media right now so I got a lot of
good stuff coming I've got five other
films I'm working on - so good stuff
here with Karen Ashley the second Yellow
Ranger for money more from Power Rangers
how's it going it's going great I'm so
happy to be in Chicago and so happy to
be at c2e2 what does it like to come to
these events and see all these these
fans who grew up watching you it's so
amazing because okay first first thing
is they walk up and they become 5 years
old again so that it's like I don't
really get to meet them as adults
because they revert back to 5 years old
but it's amazing I can't believe that
the show is still relevant it's still a
huge part of their lives
and I just can't believe the support
that we get it's it's mind-blowing so
I'm so humbled and so blessed to have
all of them in my life so there's a
Power Rangers movie coming out another
one yes do you have any involvement in
that whatsoever we get this question
almost every week not not as right now
no so who knows I'm hoping that the
powers that be will be nostalgic and
give us a nod we did the original movie
but I don't know I just hope that's good
for you I hope it's good for the fans
and I'm sure Lionsgate it's gonna give
you guys an amazing movie I'm excited
about that new cast and I just think
it's great I love it the franchise keeps
growing is there anything else that you
have going on filming why is there
anything like that yeah yeah I'm
actually working on a movie this year I
can't talk about it just now but you'll
hear about it and and May first it
everyone the whole world will know about
this movie but yeah I do that I do
obviously the Comic Cons I have my
webseries uncensored talk so yeah
there's a lot going on 2016 has not
failed me it's been a good year a very
very good year
hey it's the channel awesome booth I
didn't know you guys are gonna be here
weird right totally freaking away what's
up Tara I'm such a fan of awesome comics
oh me too it has even started yet what's
up top I don't know I just like going
like this that's fantastic
hey Rob Shh the comic book guy is gonna
come and interview us any second
so what was it been like at some of
these things like what's what's going on
like how are the fans and everything oh
my god I can't believe I get to do this
for a living
Rob tell that hack Walter asked for
vodka Dennis hey pal what's your name
Brian Porter want to be in a comic book
talk show with me sure ah everybody's
Porter here we're at c2e2 were about to
go into the DCE faces of villainy panel
and check it out talk about some comics
and what they got coming up for him
let's go
no no no no no no Darth Jar Jar no Darth
Jar Jar
apocalypse I want to ask you one
question what do you think about you
looking better than the actual movie of
course I look better than an actual
movie feel a little bit of competition
coming from Fox
that's Fox no okay this is Brian Porter
here I guess we're gonna wrap up its TV
we're gonna wrap up today c2e2 coverage
for my new friend Brian Porter Brian
Porter did a pretty good job huh
I'm Walter burn a second we're gonna see
you tomorrow at c2e2
what am I gonna be there maybe tuning to
find out